samedi une dizaine de voitures à paradé
dans Saint-Quentin en Yveline à
l'intérieur des membres du collectif la
manif pour tous toujours mobilisé contre
l'union des couples homosexuels et ce
alors que le Conseil constitutionnel
vient de valider totalement la loi nous
serons présents partout et tout le temps
et que notre combat continue nous
rentrons aujourd'hui en résistance
l'opposant à la loi se compare même aux
résistants de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
lors de la deème Guerre mondiale c'était
la l'intégrité physique de la France
aujourd'hui c'est l'intégrité morale
donc nous continuons un combat qui unit
le collectif je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont l'impression d'être dans
le vent qui on se disent on va dans le
sens de l'histoire moi j'aimerais dans
100 ans on verra à mon avis les gens
riront et j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'on
est tomb sur la tête et qu'on a plus
beaucoup de bon sens et moi ça me paraît
hallucinant et lunaire de devoir
manifester pour dire une famille c'est
un papa une maman et des enfants le
cortège bruillant n'est pas passé
inaperçu à Montini voisin le Bretonneux
aiguille en cour où un mariage était
célébré mais tous les passants ne
partageaient pas leur opinion comme
cette passante je vois ça je me dis que
c'est un peu ridicule la loi elle a été
votée ce matin voilà c'est quelque chose
de la République il faut l'accepter à un
moment et il faut aller de l'avant enfin
je trouve ça je trouve ça bête un homme
vient de gueuler ta gueule parce
qu'effectivement il fa un moment qui se
teste quoif et passer vraiment à autre
chose pour les membres de la manif pour
tous pas question de passer à autre
chose un grand rassemblement national
est toujours prévu le 26 mai à
Paris